welcome back dr nash not only helps her
clients lose weight
she is transforming lives take a look at
dominic and his incredible
weight loss journey working with dr nash
i lost 70 pounds in three and a half
months and reversed my type 2 diabetes
and i feel great dr nash
dominic's results are incredible first
off you have his weight loss but
secondly
you reversed his diabetes how does one
reverse
someone's diabetes right for the longest
time
physicians would tell patients that it
was what's called a progressive disease
which means
you can't get rid of it absolutely not
true you can reverse it but you have to
reverse it by using very specific steps
to tackle the actual disease for most
americans jc
eating less and moving more won't even
touch diabetes isn't that crazy
but my question now for you is though
how come some doctors can they can mask
the symptoms of diabetes
but you're able to reverse it what's the
difference here yeah the difference
is medication will always mask a problem
like that we don't
have a cure medically for diabetes
all we can do is manage it if you want
to get to the root issue
we've got to go after the hormone
problem that means we got to tackle it
with some kind of protocol usually
involving nutrition talking about the
five metabolic factors
that you always you bring to the table
for your clients uh all the time and how
does this all work
yeah so these five metabolic factors
were something i had to
find on my own when i was struggling
with my own personal obesity problem
the first one is going to be that you
have toxicity going on so
if i'm talks especially my liver if i
fatty liver that's gonna slow down my
fat loss
the second one is i can be overfed but
under
nourished 60 of americans americans get
60
of their diet from fast food and
restaurant food these days so we're just
not getting the right amount of
nutrition to turn these problems around
the next one is training the set point
our body actually learns to hold the ob
status we got to turn that around the
next one is inflammation
inflammation not only slows down weight
loss but it drives weight gain to the
belly
and then hormones which is the subject
of diabetes you can have up to eight
different low
or imbalanced hormones that are like
light switches
literally telling your body to store fat
or burn fat if you don't get those
switches in the right position
you can eat less and move more all you
want nothing's going to change you're
not going to get the change
and we can see the change in you and the
results and you
yourself are these results typical with
your clients
they are typical when my clients do what
i tell them to do
metabolic damage is a it's like
reversing a disease so we
can't dabble in something like that here
comes my cat look at that
but if you follow what i do step by step
not only are you going to lose the
hunger and lose the cravings
but you're going to lose the diabetes
and you get to fire your doctor how cool
is that
it's it's a win-win and your cat's tail
i saw your cat's tail
wiggling uh with approval there which is
fantastic that's just you know
that's how it is and you always bring a
special every week dr nash
you and your chat what's your special
this week our cat our special this week
is we have 10 only 10 spots available
at 9.97 and the only way you can get
them you guys is on the website
that las vegas now is showing on the
screen so you want to get in there
locking your spot
let me help you reverse this diabetes
but then get your normal weight and stay
there
again take advantage of dr nash's offer
by getting in touch with her
at that number you see on your screen in
las vegas now we'll be right back